if you show them your kindness
hospitality and
your happiness then they think like like
me i saw them
their happiness and then i i changed
muslim
your
david
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
so i came to turkey um
i came last monday around that tuesday
and i just came for like a little break
and also um
i came here because i need to get some
things printed
so i'm working on something so a lot of
people have been doing
this documentary you know documentary
yeah the documentary of
my search for marriage so that's
something
when you say my name a lot of people
they ask for this documentary
documentaries as a muslim
how i find her as my wife so
as muslims how do we get to know
somebody for
potential marriage etc so the
documentary was
supposed to come out four years ago it's
delayed so people always ask me when is
it coming out when is it coming up
yeah so basically yeah so what i did is
some brothers
go in contact with one brother i know he
said you know brother
i didn't think much of it and i said i'm
a bit busy
and then a few people messaged me and
they said oh you're here
and i saw your instagram and i saw some
videos you did some social experiments
here
yeah yeah yeah so i was going to see but
i was a little bit busy
so i waited and i thought i don't know
maybe you're busy you know i don't wanna
i was visiting yeah he's very busy as
well yeah so i thought you know
i'm not sure if i can find him i don't
know where he's in which part of
istanbul
but then some other brothers got in
contact and they said you know
tag him maybe alhamdulillah i put it on
instagram
and you go and contact me so i can
remember
seeing your videos first um that he was
looking to this now
he was looking and then i can remember
briefly somebody said you accepted us
now
so yeah from there i found out but
obviously i wanted to meet you today
uh no actually i'll be honest i didn't
my intention wasn't to do a video
i just wanted to meet you just to take
you out because your name is very
interesting
i just wanted to take you out you know
already told them how did you come
across this now
like where is it
sorry
i went to youtube four or five years ago
i saw something
i met muslim people at the first step in
indonesia
before that i didn't know about islam
because in korea
always mediocre uh
say about bad things you know really
yeah so so
[Music]
and they are different than i expected
they are not dangerous they are very
kind yeah
did you meet them in indonesia or in
indonesia okay
so they are very kind and nice and very
have a lot of hospitality and have a
really good attitude of their life so
i was really surprised oh islam is
different
they are just human and they have really
positive minds
that's interesting bad media yeah
thinking deception but when you met real
muslims
the character so that the the
mans yeah right it was different so
you're thinking okay
yeah they have something that i missed
because
i like i feel that because they they
have maybe something
the purpose of their life they know they
know that
because the religion teach them like
their answer because when i was young i
always thought about
actually my i'm christian but i also
thought about oh okay i was christian
but
i thought about always thinking about
the
fundamental questions like where i'm
from
who am yeah right
but i don't know the answer because
nobody nobody teach me like science
class teach you like how human
science tells you how things work but
they don't tell you
and i think islam teach me that
kinds of answers give me the answer so i
interested
when i go back to korea i also started
youtube and
talked about this kind of thoughts about
like why my feelings when i'm involved
and suddenly many people watch the video
so i have a lot of muslim friends
even korean stuff so i started hanging
out with them
and they teach me a lot of things
so i started to practice like i started
to pray i started too fast in ramadan
oh okay yeah it was did you have muslim
friends before
before after after the video after the
video some people
yeah right okay
[Music]
so i started to practice and i feel very
something new fresh and very pissed in
my mind because
before that at that period i had very
huge depression about about
with me personally it was just i
believed in
god i believed in a higher power i
didn't believe in any religion so with
me it was just you know
partying but i never found happiness
i would see people who i thought you
know success
is rich to be rich is successful but
then then i saw people who are rich
who have the cars the girls the money
people yeah they have nothing so i
didn't understand i said
i want to be like him but he's not he's
not happy
first i think it makes sense so yeah was
first and then i had
my cousin he uh committed suicide
my cousin my neighbor he handled himself
my cousin's friend hung themselves so i
was thinking a lot of
people died you know so it was making me
think
you know what's the purpose you know
sometimes you look at
this this has designed
it's design it has a purpose
so it must have a designer i was
thinking this has a designer that for
example
everything and i don't how could how
could this people have a design
and i don't you know yeah so yeah so you
say in your life with a bit
because i
you should try this is turkish this is
called a cigarette
cigarette you don't smoke it it's got
cheese
because i also have depression because
um encourage very competitive
society very competitive really
yeah and also when you're a student you
have to
study a lot and you have to go to
college and after that you have to get a
good job you have to have a lot of money
and
you have to buy a car you have to buy a
house like social pressure is too
too much too high so also many people
suicide in korea too
suicide is the most high higher in the
world very wrong
very high many people have but not not
or not not just me many people have
depression
also suicide yeah i think the reason
that happens is because
the thing is when these pressures are
even in my community when people are
like
come in suicide it's because it's these
pressures
that i've been given you know this is
what success is you need to have this
and have this and have this
so when he's looking at other people
that have that he doesn't have it
he's getting depressed so he's thinking
to himself okay you know i don't have
that what's the point you live in
you know and this is what capitalism is
doing you know they're giving us this
posting that
we are used to universities you know and
in university
i used to go ask myself why am i going
to university why
why because i want to study but or
is it because i want to prove to my
family members you know
that look i've studied
yeah so basically i would go to
university and i would say to myself
why am i going yes before i wanted to
study but then i wanted
i started my own business but i was
thinking a lot of people they go
university
so people can say oh wow you've got a
degree
it's just popular especially and then in
the uk
you
so you borrow money from the government
yeah so
i'm gonna go to university to get a
degree
to show off and then i'm gonna have
30 grand debt i owe to the government
i said why just so people can say oh
bravo
yeah it's slavery that's why i say i
found
true freedom in islam
because i'm not serving people i'm
serving the one who created me i don't
care
what you care about me what you think of
me the life for
others papers can't be
i also realized that after i come to
istanbul
the only happiness is when you serve
allah and
you have to find yourself first
you see around you look at people you
look at you know be
males females trying to look you don't
have to go to the gym
why for you oh no so girls like me
girls they're makeup the society makes
you
make women feel ugly get your nose down
get achieved okay
some people they turn into animals eyes
everything lips lips like this
yeah plastic surgery why
because you have to look a certain way
how is this freedom how is the freedom
that you can't go
outside with no makeup how could you say
to me okay i'm free
really can you go outside with no makeup
no no why
well because i don't you're asleep and
that's what islam came to do to
take you away from slavery to mankind
to slavery to allah because being slaves
it frees you you don't care about this
person thinks this off
if you're interested yeah
how you met muslims and muslims change
your mind
right if you met bad muslims they
wouldn't support the narrative
what you're watching the media you
wouldn't think are this true but the
fact that you met and that's right you
know the prophet salallahu
he said i came for nothing but to
perfect
good character having good character i
know a lot of japanese and koreans
they have they have good manners yeah
there's so many people good man as you
know
i've noticed that but you see
the when the prophet came the pagan
arabs
yeah they had so when the prophet says
he came to perfect good character to
give people good character
he's talking about because you can have
bad character with allah
how do you have bad character allah you
don't obey him you don't listen to him
so the quran used to say that allah
angels
are girls and having girls was bad so
they say allah's angels are girls
and they would worship other gods this
is bad character
towards allah and to have good character
towards allah is
you worship him alone you know
at first of course this was strange
because i i was not used to it but
after after the after playing extra fast
i know something something like this
inside it is hard to explain but
feeling it yeah and then
i want to know it more yeah so you you
went to the mosque and you started
praying
yeah they have a muslim not many but
there is
all right did you pray to god
did you pray to god or would you just
fast and then pray you didn't know what
you were doing
did you pray to god like you know guide
me or oh yeah
i said i'd say right what would you say
when you first pray
what was because i'm losing my mind so i
want to find
where i have to go and can you guide me
like this way
and then he answered me like yeah yeah
right i feel that because he didn't
answer me like oh come on but
i feel that yeah some people think
you're gonna have a light yeah
white light yeah i think they're also
like
i feel like kind of things like there is
something guide me very strongly
yeah as well i feel that so after that
oh yes
i i want to be a muslim
so australian yeah how long after that
like i
started i think half a year maybe
half year i studied islam half year
about half a year yeah and then yeah
like me i studied for
two three years i was looking to look
because me
i have to be sure about something to
give it my all i have to be sure
otherwise
i think that course is very important
like if you fully understand then after
you convert islam then you can
so then you accepted islam here no so
that's why
the step is
that's quite good after i became a
muslim i have a really good life to do
i overcome my depression yeah yeah
no i'm i'm not i haven't depressed so
you had depression before
yeah i don't know but i don't
but now i i was very
strong with myself like oh i have to do
this i have to decide
i have to prepare this i have to do next
next language
very stressful life but now i don't live
like that like i just
now i'm just relaxed and just do my work
and
well even if there's hardship it's just
testable a lot and i can
i'll always give me the hardship that i
can overcome so and he always planned
for me he's with me so
whatever i can do everything yeah now i
have more confidence and
more relaxed my mind you're chasing the
real
goal instead of right right more smile
more happiness
yeah we talk with people
how was it telling your family
because i know there was a video where
you said you told your mom
[Music]
i wasn't quite not easy yeah are you
close to your mom or your dad
uh that was okay but mom
yeah that they he didn't care about that
much about
me opposite my mom was okay my daddy
she doesn't worry about religion she
worries about
the danger do you think oh if if you
join
islam then maybe you can join terrorism
or something and or something someone
can attack you because of your religion
also yeah so i persuade you for
that it's not dangerous religion but she
also worried she's still worried
but i'm the only one good thing is i'm
doing youtube now she
can see my youtube channel so i show
muslims live
how they peaceful and how they are nice
and kind so
now she's getting
understand more understand understand so
now she
doesn't talk didn't talk
bad no still still she's worried about
that for her to think like that that's
normal that's not my best form again
but my mom is a very very good person
she
always teach me a good thing always say
me
be humble and be modest and so
i think that's also teach about islam so
that's good i think with me when i look
at like reverse
like ourselves you know um
i think it's um like even sister lauren
booth i'm going to go see now
i'm going to meet her and her husband
with me and my wife um
even her i believe allah picks reverts
people who come to islam
it's your job to share that message with
your family
so it's not our last plan is not just
you accept islam
our last plan is you will deliver it to
your family
same with me so that's why like for
example
my family members they come to islam
yeah same with you your mom your dad you
never know
you know so you need to see it as a
mission
because but it doesn't stop with you
it's that you you never know maybe you
might be the reason why maybe thousands
of people will accept in
south korea i don't know you know
so that's why for example when i first
came to islam i never thought
i'm gonna do video of youtube i just
said i'm gonna do my tower
you know i like tower talking to people
but now i've got youtube platform
you know i never knew i'm gonna have
this i never planned it i don't even
like me before i didn't like videos
camera
it's not me my friends they said oh do
it do it you know
and slowly it grew so you should
see it like that and each
so if somebody's watching this video
maybe a christian maybe a buddhist
maybe a muslim what message would you
give them so if there's someone there
who's thinking about islam number he's
not sure what advice would you give them
if they're thinking about my family i'm
scared
i think my advice is i i think i don't
deserve to give advice to someone
yeah but i want to say that
don't be try too much
like i mean like just show your life
and talk with them like
like normally i think that's enough
because um
if you strike too much if you struggle
that
oh i have to make him usually i have to
make a muslim
then that make more better effects
if you show them your kindness
hospitality and your happiness then
they think like like me i show them
their happiness
and then i i change to muslim i change i
i
deliver to islam but if they say
oh believe islam is good why you don't
believe this if they force you
then i i don't want to believe because
why
why you force me yeah yeah so i think
we don't need to like force them but if
if you showed your happiness then i
think they can interest in islam
then after that we have to give them
knowledge and give them so basically
show them islam not with speaking
but with your actions this is this is
very important you know because a lot of
us
today we live in a time where everything
is superficial
everything so you know we just think
okay if i memorize this
and memorize that and i speak like this
and i speak like that it doesn't mean
nothing
yeah if you're arrogant and you think
you know it all yeah
some people they come to islam very
harsh with their family
what are you talking about because this
shows you
that allah guided you when you are
arrogant it's like saying
i guided myself it takes time
something to take five months six months
one year three years five years
you can't expect sudden changes in
people you know
oh yeah stop drinking alcohol it doesn't
work like that
you want pizza
so yeah guys like
it just shows you the beauty of islam
and you know it's it's not
well obviously practicing is you try
your best you know
but i've always wondered to myself you
know when i speak to christians but i do
speak to different people i just don't
understand
why is it so hard to worship allah alone
i ask the christians like why is it so
hard why why do you need
jesus or someone else can you not just
worship god alone
i don't understand you know it's just so
simple and that's the only thing allah
asks you just worship me alone
but people for some reason you have to
go for jesus some people go from
prophet muhammad yeah it said you know
but yeah
that was his story you can check his
youtube channel i'll put the link
below and yeah it was a pleasure and if
you come to the uk
let's know yeah uh it would be nice to
take you around we'll show you
you know speaker's corner speaker's
corner
okay youtube i speak it's gonna this is
a historical place in london
for 150 years we go there to do darwin
so different people come
yeah it'll be nice if you come to london
we'll go and see that
yeah sisters